and Tarantino famously he's talked to me
about it he hates it he hates it when
his actors fall asleep on the set
because filmmaking can be very tedious
you're sitting around for a long time
you're not needed for a while and if an
actors in their seat and they fall
asleep in their chair he punishes them
how does he punish them he has a very
well not it's not his personally
sorry
[Applause]
oh he has a large sex toy it doesn't
come long to him it's just for the four
people that fall asleep man it's purple
thank you a large purple sex toy yeah
you know in the shape of a penis it's
called a dildo yeah I didn't want to say
it like that word is used every yeah
it's good that he was Israelite yeah
it's so ever use that word and he'll
he'll late first of all I feel like the
prosecutor in a case right here right
and then he will he will lay that device
on top of someone if they were asleep
and take a picture yeah then you go on
the wall of shame but I would never fall
asleep yeah cuz I don't want to fall
asleep no you don't yeah I mean certain
actors don't care like I would wake you
know Kurt up but he wouldn't take Kurt
Russell Russell's so cool like doesn't
care I take a picture of her Russell
with a dildo he's like yeah I did
you